this is june 22nd
1961. can you recall your earliest
memories of race you grab that bat and
you do what's right
i don't think so this is in your blood
all right this is where you belong boy
montgomery is a pretty town with a
pretty ugly side to it
[Music]
get out of here i was in a riot and i
walked right
through it unharmed what is the point
we're trying to make
maybe i could go around college campuses
talking to students about the neutral
calls
the hell do you think you're doing
son i'm starting to wonder if you are
aware of the poison
in the apple that you have bitten into
you know this movement is about more
than just voting rights we're trying to
change the world
you want to jeopardize your whole life
or some grand principle isn't that what
they're doing
some of these old boys around here they
really meant to do you some harm
i bet you ain't happy you came to
montgomery now boy
so what's gonna happen next
[Music]
[Music]
you gotta draw the line somewhere you
stop right now they're gonna kill him
there's gonna come a time when something
really bad happens and you're gonna have
to decide
which side you are not choosing is a
choice
ain't you supposed to be non-violent now
i'm having a real big problem with that
right now
[Music]
lift the barrel aim and shoot wait
[Music]
wait
you seem well rested after your nap this
afternoon does that always help
help what your memory i don't know what
the hell you're talking about
you asked me to come get you you said
you couldn't handle the farm anymore
i would never say that you did dad
what kind of doctor is your boyfriend
he's my husband
he's not a doctor he's a nurse you know
that
heard you went swimming daddy
first time in the pacific ocean i know
what you're up to
you want to take advantage because you
think i've lost my
marbles
who do you think paid for this house
your mother warned you last night dad
you know mom's not here
what's the matter they take away your
wings
when they found out you weren't quite
the manly man they thought they hired
now you're just another housewife you
think you can do and say whatever you
want
you know where the door is my friend
hear that
two hearts
[Music]
heaven doesn't want him and he'll keep
sending him back
the sickness hangs over the city like
putrid fog
bodies are piled higher than narrow
streets
it's as if the day of judgment has
finally arrived
i'll give you some advice leave tone
while you can i saw her the other day
she was acting bloody peculiar
there's only one thing that can explain
it she made a pact with the devil
no where to run witch
[Music]
what's to happen to me they'll try to
break you
like they did to the rest of us
fear not my child salvation is at hand
there's something wicked at work in that
place
[Music]
just the devil insider
my will is greater than yours
confessed
nobody's safe
go down
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you doing oh i was just playing
with this lamp oh
i'm star short for star break assume
yours is barbara nope
just barb playing old barb
i want to thank barbara starr for
hosting tonight's talking club and we're
making their hot dog soup i like the
salt
i like the hat dad it's not as runny as
it usually is
what does she drink i hope she gives me
bigger tea love big tea she loves big
teeth
even if it's just two eyes on a bunch of
teeth
look my new phone case i love it it's
like i'm listening to the ocean wait we
don't have cell phones
i know i'm gonna take it home and glue
it to our landline
[Music]
i'm barb and this is star number again
please sir 6
we're in 124.
[Applause]
welcome to willie's wonderland spend the
night cleaning willy's wonderland
and i will pay to have your car fixed
deal
you are officially on staff let's get
the hell out of here
i can't stand to hear a grown man scream
this place has a dark history
i know the [ __ ] story they told you
it's a lie
you're here to be a human sacrifice
have you been listening to a word i've
been saying
he's gonna die in here but he won't
listen to me
[Music]
ah
we're going to willy's
he's not trapped in here with them we
are trapped in here with him
it's birthday time i enjoy a man a few
words
you are strong you are important
you matter
[Music]
says what happened someone destroyed my
house
where's carl i think someone took him
who would say call
sue local banker carl buttons
abducted from his home in what appears
to be a violent struggle hey big
carl's in trouble turn on channel 2 news
is there anything you want to say to the
people
i know you're out there carl i know i'll
see you again
[Music]
oh [ __ ] they kidnapped my brother should
i get my gun
i'll get my gun mrs buttons usually in a
missing person case people call the
police before they call the media
carl's such a sweet man why would anyone
take him
this is a photo of me and carl in case
you need it for all the
press conferences can you think of
someone who might want to harm your
brother
nope oh dear no
no people don't fear you i can't trust
you to handle my business
if people don't fear you let them go
oh i shoot you in the face with this gun
that's my vagina you're gonna shoot me
in the vagina no i respect that
area it's not nice to point guns at
people
paul isn't the guy who gets kidnapped
he's the guy runs off on his wife
if this whole kidnapping thing is fake
you need to come clean
so if you did something i can help you
are you afraid what
yes
i am strong knock knock you got a body i
am important
i am enough don't you think so
i think so too
it's been a weekend of horror in yuba
county a weekend of chaos and loss
can you uh not kill my vibe it's a good
day don't you think it's a good day
i've done nothing wrong i just want my
husband back
i swear these white [ __ ] are crazy
[Music]
are you okay
[Music]
she said she was feeling better we see
that regularly with schizophrenia
but it can't be cured
okay hanging in there
[Music]
honey your father's gonna take the door
off the hinges if you keep locking it
[Music]
did you hear that there was a girl next
door screaming for help
ryan there's nobody out here there's a
little girl in your attic i saw her
there's no one up there she's lying
you're telling me that your neighbor
kidnapped a little girl and has her
chained in her attic
i just need you to trust me i do all
right
there's no one up there your mind is
just playing tricks on you
please stay away from that house this is
a serious accusation one that'll likely
have equally serious consequences
what the hell right he said she works
monday through friday more than helpful
to mention it was at her school
get it together
she's not real
[Music]
[Music]
i don't care what if it was me i'm not
just gonna sit here
your mind is just playing tricks on
[Music]
[Music]
youtube
[Applause]
you have any idea what those markers are
they look pretty ancient
the track's in here it's definitely
bravo team they don't just disappear
where the hell are we that lightning it
hit those markers and it took us
somewhere
guys so what
are we like guardians of the galaxy now
on our six
yeah bros
holy [ __ ]
did you see that thing
this is officially above my paygrade
i don't care what those creatures are
destroy them
and close the gateway
i'm getting it
so you have to find the three
and brightest lights there that make the
triangle these ones
and that's where the milky way is
it's good to get back on the road again
don't you think
but how about just exploring the outer
regions of
fifth gear
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm on the edge
[Music]
all right if you had one wish in the
world
what would it be i wish this holiday
wouldn't end
so can you tell that it's gotten worse
[Music]
i'd like to make a speech i uh
well maybe maybe sam will do it for you
i'd love to do it for me
now as most of you will know i am slowly
losing my ability to remember
and i definitely wouldn't be here if it
weren't for this man next to me
i want to be remembered for who i was
but not for who i'm about to become
[Music]
it's not fair to you it's not about fair
it's about love
no accept i want to see this through
with you to the end
[Music]
you know a very wise man once said we
will not
starve for lack of wonders
but from lack of wonder
why do you keep closing your laptop
every time i walk by
you look stressed
[Music]
work's been uh crazy
i've always wanted to change the world
how
amazon is for drugs
but you can't buy drugs on the internet
what if you could
using bitcoin i just made 75 grand
in the last 90 minutes baby that's 1.2
million
a day
this guy's the first millennial gangster
you're gonna crack this the
old-fashioned way asian podium
everything they know they learned off a
screen
not staring down the barrel of a gun
experience matters oh
when you snatch them up send me a fax
the dark neck something special came in
the mail
the game is changing it's going to be
every suburb in america
this website needs to be shut down
immediately
i'm the one's gonna bring this brick
down
you crossed this lab and ain't no going
back
you're getting obsessive
we get in my conspiracy to commit murder
checkmate come on hold your breath
what are you doing with my money
this thing is going to outlive all of us
[Music]
growing up in a religious town like ours
sins were dreaded
even feared you and your little posse
are parading around school calling
yourselves the seven deadly sins
from now on you will walk in the path of
the lord
once people started calling us the sins
everything changed
ladies it's time we take our sins
to the next level psalmist spirit
what's going on this is a devil chant
he wants to meet you he wants you to say
his name
aubrey miller she went missing last
night we're all in this together okay
satan trembles when he sees god face to
face
they are asking for trouble with that
behavior
[Music]
stop
i'm going insane
we are so tired of being good little
girl
don't you want to be bad for once in
your life
[Music]
i've been thinking to make with my hands
by myself
a wooden puppet
[Music]
pinocchio try say something
i have a hug my son is born from one day
to the next what do you mean
from one day for one minute to the next
watch me
and one and two if you do like me in two
or three days
you'll be walking by your grenade
[Applause]
he's a puppet like us
who are you
i know a certain place called the field
of miracles
[Music]
pertinent praises how come in prison
what's going on with us
and now ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
how did you grow up it's a secret you
know
i don't want to be a puppet i want to
become a boy like all the others
[Music]
you